nous déjà à nous tout en a fait un
groupe whatsapp avec les victimes donc
on échange souvent avec elle est la
première chose qui nous a ému c'est
qu'elle formait déjà un bloc extrêmement
solidaire ess qui est très très émouvant
c'est de les voir toute la une vingtaine
qui ont des profils très différents il y
avait des femmes qui étaient très jeunes
et avaient des femmes qui étaient déjà
des femmes d'un âge assez adulte etc et
on voit que malgré la diversité de leur
profil de leur caractère de la manière
dont elles ont réagi tout finalement ont
été broyés une rue la façon de faire de
cet homme et par le contexte c'est à
dire que tout disait mais à l'époque qui
nous aurait entendu qui nous aurait cru
qui aurait pris ça au sérieux et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut vraiment rendre
hommage à ascq a fait demi tour en terme
d'espacé médiatique mais aussi l'espace
empathique c'est-à-dire de possibilités
en fait que cette parole et s'expriment
et c'est vrai que non seulement c'était
très très fort de les voir là parce
qu'on se rend compte quand un gros couac
en 2022 on se dit que la parole de 26
femmes maintenant vaut moins que celle
d'un homme qui dit auprès de la justice
donc nous on se tient auprès d'elle par
rapport au procès bâillon qu'on veut
leur imposer on a lancé hier avec nous
toute une campagne de soutien de celle
fille de soutien que vous pouvez
retrouver sur les réseaux sociaux de de
nous tout point d'anciens draps à leurs
côtés et c'est vrai que je me mets un
peu
j'imagine ce que doit penser ppda face à
ces spectacles alors justement justement
ma deuxième extrait on a aussi découvert
le témoignage de marie laure e delattre
conseiller en entreprise qui révèle
avoir été violée par ppda le 18 1985
alors qu'elle était âgée de 23 ans ce
jour là elle retrouve le bda parce qu'en
s'en aller boire un pot ça ne se serait
pas malheureusement passé comme elle le
voudra bien me suis retrouvé dans
l'ascenseur avec lui et je me suis dit
bon comme il m'avait dit qu'on allait
voir impôts je me suis dit je vais aller
boire un pot sur la terrasse est en fait
je me suis retrouvé dans sa chambre et
après je les ai vus tout nu comme un ver
se frotter sur son canapé tu dis mais
qu'est ce que vous faites là moi je ne
suis pas bon pour ça et j'ai pas bougé
je me souviens juste que j'étais allongé
qui m'a enlevé en pantalon et ma culotte
qu'il est rentré ding dong ding dong moi
j'étais collé comme ça c'est tout ce qui
s'est passé là c'est une chose que des
mois mais c'est pas ça c'est
bout de viande j'en ai besoin je le
prends et je m'en vais quand il a fait
fin qui a giclé en moi juste après
c'était je savais que ça paierait donc
il est dans une autre dimension je pense
rien ah oui c'est une jeune femme qui
avait 23 ans au moment des faits s'est
elle était stagiaire pour pour ppda elle
elle rêvait voilà du 2-2 payet de show
biz elle a été très très contente que
ppda lavit au festival de cannes et
c'est vrai que ce qu'elle raconte est
extrêmement fort et c'est la première
fois qu'elle parle elle raconte en fait
qu'elle a été donc voir un film qui
s'appelait last night or elle voit ça un
peu comme un peu la prémonition ce que
va effectivement last night elle a vécu
une nuit assez terrible et du coup ils
l'invitent à boire un verre elle est
persuadée cheveux qui m'ont boire un
verre au martinez l'hôtel ou où dormait
ppda il lui dit même qu'ils auraient
qu'il y aurait un grand ministre à
ministre imminent pour boire un verre
avec eux elle le suit et puis et puis
elle se retrouve dans sa chambre et elle
explique les faits qu'on vient
d'entendre juste à l'instant mais
guillaume main ce qui est frappant quand
on écoute le témoignage de ces femmes
c'est une sorte de mode opératoire ppda
qui se dessine ou en fait au prince
jouissait de son statut de présentateur
star du jt pour leur faire miroiter des
perspectives professionnelles et espérer
avoir des rapports sexuels en échange et
l'autre chose qui est qui est frappante
c'est que ppda ne s'arrêtait pas de
harceler les femmes tant qu'un homme
n'intervenait pas entre lui et la femme
sara keene avait en fait aucun respect
pour les femmes et seule l'autorité d'un
homme entre guillemets faisait foi et
c'est ce qu'on apprend avec le
témoignage de ces vingt tables alors
rien de rien de témoignages qui est très
fort c'est celui de margaux coquilles
aujourd'hui enseignante et qui explique
que ppda l'a violée lorsqu'elle avait 17
ans il continue ensuite en décrivant
comment alors âgé de 24 ans ppda tenter
une nouvelle fois lui demander des
faveurs sexuelles après un jt regarder
avant d'avoir arrive il s'assied sur son
bureau et là il me dit ce journal a été
très difficile je suis très stressée et
là une des braguettes
son pantalon il sort son sexe et et il
me dit voilà j'ai besoin d'une petite
fellation non excusez moi c'est pas
correct a dit l'année
je suis vraiment très stressée j'ai
besoin d'une catherine une petite
catherine là je me suis levé j'ai haussé
le ton jeudi non monsieur c'est hors de
question
et là il a répondu eh bien dans ce il a
un bras guetter son pantalon et il m'a
répondu pas dans ce cas là mademoiselle
au revoir
il ya deux femmes qui ont témoigné
qu'ils étaient mineurs au moment des
faits qu'elle décrit donc ça c'est un
une partie très forte elles se sont
réunies dimanche soir l'émission a été
enregistrée lundi et ils ont décidé de
parler certaines de dos c'était
bouleversant et pour le moment la
justice enquête mais elles sont amers
c'est pour ça qu'elles ont décidé de
parler parce arrière une seule plein de
celle de florence porcel qui ne serait
pas prescrite disant qu'elles ont envie
que ça sorte mais rien mais elles sont
aussi amer parce que patrick poivre
d'arvor a les a attaqué en diffamation
sakal calomnieux et qu'il ya cette femme
qui se retrouve aujourd'hui avec une
plainte alors qu'elles sont elles
estiment qu'elles sont les victimes et
qu'elle trouve que cette façon d'agir
est extrêmement violente pour elle et
toi tu es juste elles sont amers et en
même temps elles attendent ce procès
c'est dire que comme l ont été privés de
leur propre procès elles saisissent va
très bien patrick poivre d'arvor va se
retrouver au procès et là tu vas devoir
nous affronter tout et c'est vrai que ce
qui est très très intéressante par
rapport à ce que tu dit myriam c'est la
manière aussi dans la honte se construit
parce qu'on a l'impression d'avoir été
en porte-à-faux c'est à dire quand on
est une jeune dans la galère et
notamment dans les métiers de l'art du
journalisme de la politique et ses bas
on éduque et effectivement essayé de
voir clignoter un peu des opportunités
du dessin et donc quand une personne
aussi importante qui a acheté statut
semble nous distinguer et ben oui c'est
toujours quelque chose recensés dans ma
vie de positif et il faut que tu n' ya
elle ne fais pas ta mijaurée ne reste
pas dans ton coin donc tu y vas en
confiance et donc et c'est ça c'est
quand j'ai déjà dit ici que on parle
souvent des de ces hommes accusés dont
la carrière s'envole mais ce qu'on parle
de toutes ces destins de femmes qui ont
été discriminés parce que très
clairement ce genre d'homme leur dit
maintenant tu fais ce que je te demande
ou alors tu l'auras pas ton stage il ya
l'ancien patron de tf1 qui a également
été questionné par les journalistes de
médiapart nonce paolini il a insisté sur
le fait qu'il ne savait pas qu'il aurait
pris les dispositions qui s'imposent si
ces informations étaient remontés à ses
oreilles je connais bien non je peux
vous dire que non ce n'était pas du tout
les arrivées en prêt en plus voilà il
arrive après et
n'était pas du tout regardé je t'adore
regardez c'est à la fois
stupéfiants et révoltant
abusé de la position dans laquelle on
est pour se livrer à ce genre de
harcèlement ou plus
c'est révoltant si dans une entreprise
comme tf1 on l'a déçu évidemment des
sanctions ont été prises si on l'avait
su on aurait pris les dispositions qui
s'imposent et en tout cas moi le premier
tous les témoignages disent que c'était
un son bureau après la conférence de
rédaction et après 21h à 21h à tf1 il
n'y a plus personne donc qui pouvait
savoir alors un grand monsieur annonces
n'ont rien des poulies il savait pas du
tout ce qui se passait après les autres
je sais pas mais nonce paolini en tout
cas c'est sûr et certain wii alors quand
il me dit que il y avait personne à tf1
c'est faux parce que justement le mode
opératoire ppda n'était de flée faire
venir après le jt il y avait les
activités l'association nous dire que
personne n'était au courant c'est faux
et même à l'époque les rh savait qu'il
fallait éviter de lui mettre deux jeunes
de jolie assistante pour l'accompagner
donc dire ça c'est un peu d'avancé aux
autochtones ariane à venir je joue
souple et vous jeu qu'on dit ou du
soutien de ppda vous êtes romancière
vous l'avez vous nous de nous avait déjà
raconter votre histoire avec lui si vous
avez pensé de tous et tous ces
témoignages moi je ne soutiens pas j'ai
souhaité témoigner de son mode
opératoire par contre je pense que ce
sont des faits qui remontent à une autre
époque on ne peut pas tomber dans
l'anachronisme
et en plus on parle de système ppda j'ai
en fait c'était un système beaucoup plus
vaste un système de société ou en fait
les hommes de pouvoir abuser de leur
pouvoir les femmes jouaient certaines
joué le jeu avec la promotion canapé qui
s'ensuivait c'était beaucoup plus
globale je vois pas pourquoi lui devrait
porter chapeau pour tout un système
patriarcal
voilà c'est parti c'est les autres le
cautionner ou fermer les yeux et voilà
sa jumelle et sandra quand vous avez
entendu la fin ils disent émus sur moi
il m'a enlevé le pantalon il m'a pénétré
là c'était pas un système ses interviews
des faits qui doivent être vérifiés
de chocolat
syndrome de stockholm c'est juste une
nuance dans les propos donc j'ai dû
annuler l unilatéralisme avec des
positions toujours qui tombe dans
l'excès on peu pas mal gamme et des
actes très déplacé inélégant manque de
respect envers les femmes approche
inappropriée avec un viol par la
violence physique qui est très grave
n'ait pas respect pour les femmes qui se
font violer par la violence physique eh
ben je moi j'ai là que la violence
physique 1 c'est la contrainte la
surprise l'alliance et cetera mais moi
je pense que celle dont on doit parler
aujourd'hui vraiment pour parler de
patriarcat c'est de ces mots qui
déguisent les viols par exemple
promotion canapé moi c'est pour ça que
je suis restée reconnaissante par
exemple à certains cinéastes fepaci vous
avez vu ce film juste comment il
s'appelle ce film sur la drogue bref j
oublie son fort et où on voit une fille
qui a besoin d'argent pour s'acheter de
la drogue parce qu'il est addict et on
voit la scène vraiment où son
psychologue fait comprendre que c'est ok
si elle veut bien couché avec lui on
peut enrobé sa du terme
son canapé c'est aussi
un cinéaste qui l'a filmé au moment où
elle sort de la sq de la chambre à
coucher qu'elle est comme une merde et
que qu'on comptera franchement que ce
n'est que l'une des nuances de la
manière dont on vit l on va voir un
autre témoignage celui stéphanie khayat
qui avait fait la une de libération avec
six autres victimes il ya quelques mois
qui raconte encore sous le choc la
fellation que ppda lui aurait proposé
lors de son premier jour de stage je
regarde je suis rentré dans le bureau le
téléphone a sonné je me suis retourné
vers la bibliothèque
et cinq minutes après
cinq minutes après j'avais son sexe dans
ma bouche
ge est anorexique je posais 30 kg on met
rien dans la bouche d'une anorexique et
encore moins un sexe d'homme et son sexe
avait un goût très bon et ça fait des
semaines que ça manque c'est dans dix
ans mais ça veut dire qu'il s'était lavé
et donc il savait ce qu'il allait me
faire
c'est assez terrible cc c'est
certainement l'un des témoignages
auraient trouvé le loin plus fort de
tout ça non pas que voilà il ya mais
c'est vrai que ce qu'elle raconte en
plus ce qui est assez dur pour ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que dans le bureau
de ppda il ya quand même le portrait de
sa fille solenn qui est elle même qui
était elle-même anorexique est morte
padano ici parce qu'elle s'est suicidée
en se jetant sous les rails dada métro
donc tout le contexte est hyper violent
pour cette jeune femme qui elle-même
anorexique qui ne pèse que 30 kg qui
s'adresse à un homme dont la fille est
elle-même anorexique donc c'est assez
assez compliqué l'yonne moi j'ai trouvé
ça vraiment historique est très fort et
très crus et fatima je suis d'accord
avec vous moi je les ai trouvés très
forte ces femmes sans de groupes comme
ça soude et sort deux soeurs d'un
fortune comme le dit florence méro recel
premièrement florence porcel c'est la
lanceuse alerte c'est grâce à elle et à
cause d'elle que tout a commencé ensuite
tout ce qui se passe là c'est à cause de
ppda parce que quand il va quotidien et
kolya l'interview complaisons aimons la
sonde yann barthès et qui nivelait les
anonymes à tout ça il se prend après la
couverture de libération avec les femmes
face caméra et son soin jeu ou diront
non on aurait fait on va pas se mentir
si on l'a vu sur le plateau sinon
référendum une table où on a peut-être
par oui non mais ce que vous auriez sa
femme il y aurait peut-être eu moins de
complaisance malgré tout par un billet
de mytf1 une
autocritique mais je pense que ça peut
évoluer le trader sur na li 6 qui
doivent évoluer bon c'était quand même
très formaté et très plan-plan il
ajoutant après je pense je vous dis je
vous dis la vérité je prends je prend la
défense de deux jeux prend la défense de
barthez là dessus je pense que quand
vous avez ppda qui vous dit je vais
venir parler de tout ce qui s'est passé
je pense qu'avant il doit poser quelques
contraintes dire voilà je veux tel telle
question si le won de vérité syrie je
peux vous dire non mais je vais vous
dire aussi aux non et je le dis s'il
nous avait dit je viens en parler mais
ils vont poser de telles questions
telles questions telles questions on
aurait fait comme quotidien il faut pas
jouer ils ont dit sur ces éléments de
langage quand même
un signe de la culture dois je vous dis
la vérité s'il y avait eu un deal mais
je pense que c'est ce qui a eu c'est
qu'ils ont dû se dire mais d'ici là il
vient mais cyril est on obligé ce je
vous dis sinon je pense que c'est un
deal qui était favorite au togo quand on
vous a imposé des dites vous les avez
mis à jour vous l'aimez à des questions
vous avez dit ok les questions c'est que
entre vous et montréalais après un jour
jean luc mélenchon m'a dit je veux pas
d'eric naulleau j'ai pas prêt et non
loin de pointe à l'époque je pense en
revanche que vient de voir là il y aura
vraiment un avant et après je crois
véritablement n'ont pas dormi tout seul
mais le mythe ou français paris ses
débuts tout français dans l'histoire du
viol je pense que ce qui se passe est
historique on apprend encore consciente
de conscience historique à tous en même
temps siouplaît depardon juste oui la
justice va pas forcément suivre aussi
l'anachronisme et des faits qui se sont
déroulés il ya 20 ans ne peut plus
finale et je suis content que la terre
était déjà incriminé moi je rêvais
sandra j'ai une question à vous poser
puis il serait le le le l'intérêt de ces
femmes aujourd'hui à visage découvert qu
un certain âge qu'on des enfants
peut-être communicati saurait laisser
ces prescriptions ils n'ont rien à
gagner a dit la challengeuse à lui tout
le buzz avec ses fans puissent
aujourd'hui c'est toujours lui qui
viennent dire j'ai eu un sac de mariée
cherche le buzz l'ambiance a changé dans
l'extrait je dis pas qu'elles disent pas
des faits qui ont pu avoir lieu mais
l'ambiance a complètement changé moi je
l' ai vu que je chante j'ai été violée
j'étais restée terre j'ai quand j'étais
là il ya quinze ans le monde était
différent c'était assez drôle et tendre
en attendant votre trousse que mais
c'est pas la même être accro lourdingue
sans violer les dents longues dans
l'enquêté même 26 témoignage de ya
vingt-six témoignages dont sept qui
correspondent à des viols
malheureusement ils sont prescrits c'est
violent donc ils ne pourront pas aller
en justice mais il ya quand même 26
témoignages qui raconte soit du
harcèlement soit de l'agression sexuelle
toit du viol et je sais pas ce que tu
dis ça mais en fait moi je suis d'accord
avec toi j'ai commencé en disant ça y
est
changement de posture on va dire et de
façon de visualiser en fait ceux d'antan
pas en revanche souvenons nous qu'à
toutes les époques déjà c'était déjà le
viol est déjà condamnée à toutes les
époques il ya eu des personnes qui sont
montées au créneau peut-être que tu te
souviens de cette émission avec bernard
pivot qui reçoit matzneff et il ya une
militante féministe qui le confronte et
bernard pivot il se fout de sa gueule
qu'est ce que c'est que cette hystérique
donc ça ça a évolué tu as bien pensé
bien raison il n'empêche que la pp da
pour s en sortir juste par un mea culpa
les dossiers sont prescrits aujourd'hui
qui pourrait rentrer dans l'histoire
juste en disant oui c'était l'hymne et
au peuple qu'est ce que j'aime et redire
à l'hémicycle
franchement je sais la dernière victime
l'halluciné ses devoirs en fait tous ces
spectres tous ces femmes qui viennent du
passé parce que pour lui ce n'est même
pas des femmes c'est du consommable je
sais comme dsk qui sont envoyé des sms
dans la sphère du carlton en appelant
les femmes le matériel je pense que là
il doit les voir mais ces genres c'est
comme c'est la première fois qu'il voit
des chats palinger bourse apple n'a pas
du tout le comportement de ppda c'est
honteux oui mais vrai c'était un
comportement qui était cautionner
quelque part en tout cas les gens du
mois fermé les yeux et c'est grave
eline berings justement elle était sur
le plateau lire de médiapart elle
raconte comment le silence était imposé
concernant les agissements de ppda
regardent ils ont été les impacts
dans votre milieu professionnel
énorme alors il ya deux types d'impacts
d'abord il ya le silence c'est à dire
que le style ans dans le milieu de la
télévision était absolument imposer
parlé c'était non pas le pot de fer
contre le pot de terre mais c'était la
certitude de se faire pulvériser
forcément le le pouvoir de patrick
poivre d'arvor dans la rédaction ou
l'abus de son pouvoir était tel que on
avait mais aucune chance de se faire
entendre parler c'était exploser son
avenir professionnel
si c'est pas son avenir personnel aussi
en ville les femmes très bien décrit ce
système de protection et d'immunité dont
il a bénéficié et alessandra je vous
rappelle simplement qu'il ya des faits
qui sont établis en 2013 2014 sans doute
donc vous dit c'est pas la même époque
c'est très près nous 2013 à la place
qu'elles sont plus loin que sase est ce
qu'ils étaient très forts effectivement
c'était qu'elles décrivent la manière
dont elle ne pouvait pas parler il y en
a deux qui témoignait
visage caché et qu'ils ont dit je
travaille encore et je ne peux pas me
permettre il a encore un carnet d
adresses il a encore plongé de l'iphone
il est encore puissants donc ça ça
montre effectivement il nie les faits il
faut le dire mediapart a invité il n'est
pas venu mais ça montre qu'il est il a
envie bord du pouvoir les faits alors
juste vous avez parlé de son interview
en mars 2021 sa prise de parole chez
quotidien et c'est vrai que c'est une
question qui a été posée vous avez une
compil des réponses de ces jeunes femmes
suite à la vraiment au passage de
patrick poivre d'arvor en mars 2021 dans
l'émission quotidien il essayait de
justifier un certaines de ses actions
tout en niant les faits qui lui étaient
reprochés regarder
on a découvert quelques jours après il
est absolument lunaire parce que parler
de petits bisous dans le cou parler de
séduction en fait on est tellement
tellement loin de la séduction que ça
paraît tout simplement absurde ça a
réveillé quelque chose chez beaucoup de
femmes qui jusque là ne pouvait pas ou
n'osais pas s'exprimer et manuel et
quand je la vois c'est une interview je
me dis mais mais il est bon l'animal un
on lui donnerait le bon dieu sans
confession quoi alors que nous là tout
s'est très bien qu' il n'est pas
question de consentement avec lui je lis
il sait même pas ce que c'est en fait il
prend
alors la même chose quelques
informations sur la vie de ppda depuis l
éclatement un scandale il ne sort
quasiment plus de chez lui sa dernière
apparition publique s'était aux
funérailles de jean pierre pernaut où
personne ne lui adressait la parole y
compris les personnalités de tf1 qui la
fréquentent fréquenté pendant des années
plus personne ne lui rend visite à part
son frère son fils et sa nouvelle
compagne c'est une femme de 40 ans qui
l'a rencontré il ya quelques mois ça
fait quelques mois qu'il est avec elle
il a rencontré dans une soirée c'est
quelqu'un qui est issu d'un milieu qui
n'a rien à voir avec la télévision et
qui selon lui la pèseraient beaucoup et
l'aiderait à traverser ce qu'il
considère lui comme une épreuve puisque
je rappelle qu'il réfute toutes les
accusations et une injustice là ça va
être difficile de se défendre avec ces
témoignages qui sont accablants mais lui
considère ça comme une épreuve et sa
nouvelle compagne l'aiderait à à la
traversée karine berfield ci qui dit
avoir subi un comportement inapproprié
par ppda le journaliste a évoqué comment
la journaliste évoqué comment l'ancien
présentateur de tf1 avait balayé son
témoignage en disant qu'il ne se
souvenait plus d'elle et qu'elle avait
sûrement été déçu de ne pas avoir été
des luttes son coeur regarde j'en parle
et on me disait ah toi aussi
sous-entendu c'est pas grave c'est un
dragueur lourd
et non c'est pas de la drague c'est une
prise de pouvoir sur le corps des autres
femmes qu'il croit à sa disposition pour
vous concernant patrick prévoit d'avoir
de son audition d'izneo qu'un souvenir
de cette fille ce sont peut-être des
personnes qui sont déçus de ne pas avoir
repéré ou de ne pas être l'élu de monde
car trouver savoir ce que ça vous
inspire la
saisie bhl mais ce n'était pas quelqu'un
qui m'attirait une seconde ils me
dégoûtent mm comme il est dans le déni
il peut pas accepter de ne pas être
irrésistible voilà c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable un tous ces témoignages